il était une fois l'espace automobile
matra pour ses 20 ans une grosse expo
prévu les dirigeants se trouvèrent fort
dépourvue quand le confinement fut venue
les voitures de l'ancienne exposition de
venait de partir et le musée était à
moitié vide
nous avons donc été obligés de réagir
très rapidement
on a analysé plusieurs idées qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire et on a décidé donc de
faire appel aux prêtres prêteurs de
romorantin et des alentours des loir et
chérien adepte de l'endroit se
proposèrent de partager leur passion une
partie de leur vie et de leur collection
ludovic et sa 304 cabriolet unis depuis
plus de 40 ans à l'époque je travaillais
sur paris donc je faisais le loir et
cher paris toutes les semaines
j'ai fait pas mal de deux sorties de
vacances des sorties entre amis
non j'ai vraiment d'aider des très bons
souvenirs
sur la douzaine de véhicules empruntés 3
le furetage jean-claude il vit
l'histoire à travers les voitures sa
passion la restauration ça me stresse
4,61 cabriolet noir savoir que ce genre
de voitures étaient fabriqués à 3 125
exemplaires
donc c'est pour ça quand on voit les
photos de la restauration sur le banc où
la voiture que tu es à l'état d'épave
avec un arbre qui avaient poussé au
milieu pour moi je me suis dit ça vaut
le coup de la restaurer parce qu'il est
très peu d'exemplaires fabriqués
si jean-claude restaure nelson réparé de
tous les véhicules de luxe qui passèrent
par son entreprise de casse auto il
retira cette ferrari pour la mettre en
expo celles ci ont la réparer
je pense l'année dernière alors le temps
est assez long en général pour réparer
ce genre de voiture et puis là on l'a
mise ici et puis après on va la mettre
en vente pour en avoir une autre bel
élan de solidarité des gens du cru voilà
bien plus qu'une expo de fortune une
passion des voitures et des hommes